pour tourner selon mary basque alain est
apparue aussi chevaux ce qu'on vérifie
si vous êtes des bon papa et qu'on fasse
une interwiew papa est-ce que vous avez
déjà regretter d'avoir eu un enfant
pardon et j'ai regretté d'avoir eu un
enfant
non vous avez déjà demander un test de
paternité parce que l'enfant avait l'air
un peu con demander un test de paternité
parce que l'enfant avait l'air un peu
vif vous avez déjà fait un enfant pour
faire plaisir à la mer non non ah non
maintenant vous vous rappelez de toutes
les mères de vos enfants oui or la
plupart oui vous avez assisté à la
naissance dernièrement vous bien sûr
vous avez filmé ah non ah ouais j'ai
assisté j'étais derrière elle moi je
voulais devant elle elle m'a dit non tu
dis que c'est mieux vous avez déjà
changer les couches de vos enfants mais
oui les biberons vous les faites à el al
est mais n'est pas très très bien au
début
ouais un peu le bordel que les couches
non l'allaitement est ce que vous avez
déjà giflé un enfant régulièrement
martin le petit martin
par exemple oui j'ai déjà oublié votre
enfant quelque part à part sur le toit
de ma voiture non vous proposez de la
drogue à vos enfants pour être sûr
qu'ils en prennent
je demande instamment cet interlude
jouer le joker je ne peux plus aller il
ya des mails elle s'arrête
est-ce que vous avez déjà demandé à
votre enfant de rien dire à la mer à
propos de l'actrice dénudées qui étaient
là pour sa carrière en fait vous arriver
ça je voudrais demander à votre enfant
de rien dire à sa mère à propos de ces
deux jeunes actrices dénudées qui
voulait juste des oui non oui tout à
fait non c'était un mais en plus ils
auraient pu en parler satan est vraiment
passionnante elle atterrit way dans la
troisième mais je serai toujours pas il
va voir d'abord étonné de regret je
n'aurai pas de vanne mais il sait même
pas qui va être drôle bayer est ce que
vous avez déjà demandé votre enfant à
propos de ces deux jeunes actrices
dénudées qui voulait juste des conseils
pour sa carrière
il est utilisé notre enfant pour draguer
des filles dans les jardins publics
non
je peux pas la maman est toujours avec
la petite vous ai déjà fait travailler
votre enfant à la non encore moi ça peut
être faire un tapis de ce match à la
légère
j'ai perdu un pognon des ordinateurs et
des pompes
j'ai regardé les télétubbies sans
prendre de drogue à la wii et je me suis
fait chier est-ce que vous avez déjà
fait oh qu'il est mignon ouagadougou 12
au bout du goût doux oui mais en gardant
sa [ __ ] maurice et pour vous aussi vous
déjà promis à sa mère que jamais au
grand jamais où la quitterai away
ah non mais ça c'est sûr c'est sûr elle
est la femme de ma vie ah oui un texto
un texto de judith pour dire que ces
barres et ça vient de tomber
est ce que votre enfant vous a déjà
appelé monsieur tellement n'était pas
habitué à vous voir la maison
je salue l'équipe d'écriture n'ont
toujours pas veillé à caresser les
cheveux de votre enfant en pensant à
l'économie d'impôt que ça vous fait
faire maurice déjà j'en viens pas
qu'elle ait des cheveux non franchement
je me suis pas pressée de son père c'est
vrai qu'elle a plus de cheveux bogard
mais paraît que si le film marche et
vous laisser pousser les cheveux c'est
vrai je vais me payer une perruque en or
à vous et collez bébé à bord à l'arrière
de votre porsche cayenne alors j'ai
juste le bébé à bord il je n'ai jamais
regretté de pas avoir pris un chien
plutôt non aucune non mais non je si je
trouve de la vanne
donc la guerre je veux revenir à un
moment et vous l'intégrer jusqu'à samedi
s'est diffusée samedi j'irai réponse
vannes demain vendredi 13 mai j'ai la
réponse tu viens on rappelle les gens et
s'en foutent rien et on tourne la vanne
est ce que vous avez peur que vos
enfants vous ressemble un jour non mais
apparemment les gens disent qu'elle me
ressemble je vais vite sans les jolies
pas d'accord